this week's 48 Hours investigates The
Disappearance and murder of a young
Alabama woman Lori slosinski vanished in
2006 shortly after she graduated from
Auburn University her disappearance
remained a mystery for more than a
decade police believe she was last with
her friend Rick Innes and they had
learned that he'd been accused of murder
before 48 Hours correspondent Peter Van
Zant reports
Auburn Alabama is home to Auburn
University
which is a major football school Jessica
ventieri is the district attorney for
Lee County Alabama in a college town it
happens that students sometimes may go
often you know they may be missing for a
little while
but they come back on June 10 2006 Lori
slosinski a recent Auburn graduate
planned to have a girls night with her
best friend Lindsey Braun she called me
around 6 30 and said I'm going to stop
by the store pick up the drink mixes and
then I'll be headed to your house
but Lori never showed up and this
Walmart video is the last image of her
initially her disappearance was treated
as a missing person's case
but everything changed when four days
after she vanished her car suddenly
exploded on a desolate cul-de-sac
the car was right here dead in the
center
engulfed in flames
Mark Whitaker is a special agent with
the Alabama State Bureau of
Investigation was Lori in this cook
Lori was not in the vehicle
Lori's mother Arlene slazinski was
beyond frightened
feelings were just unbelievable of fear
and
knowing something really bad has
happened investigators soon focused on
one of Lori's friends Rick Ennis tonight
he had anything to do with Lori's
disappearance but police say Ennis was
the last person to see Lori that day
he had scratch marks on him and there
was something else about Rick Ennis
something that happened when he was 12
years old retired state trooper John
Clark sitting back there in that seat
behind you and I said where are your
parents he looked right back at me and
he says I killed them both
Peter Van Zandt joins us right now good
morning Peter so what happened to Rick
Ennis after he killed his parents well
after he killed his parents remember he
was just 12 years old so he went into
Juvenile Detention for nine years we're
told during that time he attempted one
Escape when he turned 21 he was released
he went to Auburn Alabama worked at a
bowling alley where he met Lori
slosinski after her disappearance he
traveled about ended up in Virginia
where he met a school librarian and they
fell in love got engaged and they're
engaged to this day do you think Lori
knew that he had killed his parents she
had no idea this was a closely guarded
secret because he was just 12 years old
juvenile criminal records are kept
confidential so were the two of them
dating Lori it said you describe him as
a friend did they have more than a
friendship they did not according to
Laurie's best friends and she shared
everything in her life with them they
were never intimate it was a friendship
Rick at one point ends up leaving a
letter at her her home saying he wanted
to take it to another level and she
rejected him that is a potential motive
in this case
it seems like a lot of twists and turns
yeah yeah Peter panzan thank you you can
see Peter's report a man with the past
on 48 hours tomorrow 10 9 Central here
on CBS and streaming on Paramount Plus